madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 28 juillet
la suisse est sous le choc après
l'accident des gorges de 5,6 barque qui
a fait 19 morts et de disparus
tous participent et à une descente de
canyoning l'enquète s'annonce difficile
seule une météo imprévu semble être à
l'origine de la catastrophe
les 35 heures martine aubry a présenté
le texte de la deuxième loi au conseil
des ministres de ce matin selon elle
cent mille emplois ont déjà été créés ou
sauvegardés grâce à ce dispositif les
syndicats se montrent plus réservés
quant au medef fillier franchement
hostile ernest antoine seillière le
président du patronat sera notre invité
dans ce journal avant de partir en
vacances ionel jospin procès de
remaniement de l'été dominique gillot
remplace bernard kouchner et françois
guarch succède à jacques dont nous il
n'y a donc pas de rééquilibrage en
gouvernement pour tenir compte des
élections européennes un remaniement
technique
dénoncé par les verts et puis la france
condamnée pour torture par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est une première à l'origine de la
plainte d'un trafiquant de drogue contre
les mauvais traitements de cinq
policiers pendant une garde à vue
et puis enfin nous irons à la roque
d'anthéron à la fin de ce journal ce
petit village fête ses 19 ans de
festival consacré à la musique classique
et particulièrement au piano il a su
attirer les plus grands artistes
c'est donc la stupeur en suisse dans le
canton de berne près d'interlaken les
secouristes ont repêché un à 1 19 corps
dans les gorges de saxe inbar deux
autres personnes sont encore portées
disparues toutes participent est à une
descente de canyoning
elle était bien encadré une journée de
détente et de plaisir qui s'est
transformé en drame
après qu'un orage se soit abattue
subitement sur la région jérôme soûlard
après 24 heures de recherches et
d'efforts les sauveteurs viennent de
découvrir sous cette bâche le corps de
la dix-neuvième victime de la tragédie
de boeing
des touristes en mal d'aventuré et des
professionnels du canyoning habitués de
la vallée piégé pourtant hier en
quelques minutes par une nature devenue
intraitable
ce n'est pas exceptionnel qui lui entend
dos lorsqu'il ya un orage dans ce
torrent mais ce qui s'est passé ici est
une catastrophe
c'est en haut de ces gorges de la
rivière saxon barre que les 45 touristes
et huit moniteurs de canyoning ont été
emportées par les eaux du torrent après
qu'un orage violent a éclaté sur la
montagne
un orage prévisible selon les habitants
de la vallée
je les ai vus monter au torrent je
voulais leur dire de ne pas y aller à
cause de l'orage qui arrivait mais j'ai
pensé qu'il ne met coûterait pas
sauf ce qui passe ils connaissent les
risques on ne sait pas pourquoi elles
sont sont entrés l'arrivée à force
consoler qui l'a aidé à nos rangs y at
il eu imprudence des accompagnateurs ou
terrible concours de circonstances
les responsables de la société adventure
world qui organise dans la région ce
type de sortie pour des centaines de
touristes chaque été ne s'explique pas
ce terrible accident mais qui sont
habitués à travailler dans les eaux du
torrent
depuis cinq ans ils descendent presque
tous les jours à la rivière ils
connaissent tout de cette nature mieux
que quiconque dans la vallée par
hélicoptère sur le lac de buizingen ou
sur les berges du torrent ce soir les
recherches vont évidemment continuer car
deux personnes sont encore portées
disparues
un véritable choc pour les habitants de
la vallée qui accueille chaque année des
milliers d'amoureux de la montagne et
qui ce soir veulent tout simplement
partager le deuil des familles alors
tiré kurt et vous êtes sur place
l'enquète j'imagine s'annonce difficile
est ce qu'il faut s'en prendre à
l'affect fatalité dans cette affaire ou
bien est-ce qu'il faut incriminer
l'imprudence tout simplement écouter
benoît je pense que la justice suisse ne
se contentera pas de fatalité tant le
choc et gand ici en suisse pour
l'instant c'est vrai la priorité des
enquêteurs va à l'identification des
victimes car il faut bien imaginer que
le très violent orage a littéralement
purger toute cette montagne a roulé dans
le lit de la rivière en même temps les
victimes les troncs d'arbres et les
rochers rendant les victimes
méconnaissable qui ne facilite pas le
travail des enquêteurs alors vous l'avez
dit le bilan est pour l'instant de 19
morts il n'est pas définitive vous voyez
peut-être derrière moi deux bateaux qui
sont encore à la recherche des deux
disparus quant à la prévision de cet
orage écoutez j'ai pu obtenir le
bulletin de météosuisse la météo suisse
prévoyait bien des orages pour cette
région
montagneuse de la suisse mais elle
prévoyait des orages pour le soir
seulement et non pas pour l'après midi
et pas forcément on a dit thierry pas
forcément à cet endroit précis de la
vallée peut-être non il faut bien
imaginer que nous sommes dans une région
de montagne et que la prévision
météorologique est très difficile il
faut savoir que à une trentaine de
kilomètres il est tombé de véritables un
véritable déluge 30 à 40 litres d'eau en
quelques minutes au mètre carré alors
que ici à inter laquelle il n'est tombé
que 3 litres d'eau au mètre carré alors
environ une trentaine de kilomètres de
ce point merci thierry ses gorges et de
sacs site barre était parfaitement
connue des guides de la région elle
était même équipé avec des issues de
secours
en 95 et 96 des accidents du même type
s'était produit dans les alpes-maritimes
à l'aclu du [ __ ] faisant sept morts au
total depuis là aussi des aménagements
ont été apportés et la préfecture a
décidé de réglementer de façon très
stricte le canyoning olivier théron et
frais avec besson si tu regardes comme
ça il est praticable en ce moment si
jamais il ya un orage qui arrivent
dessus on sait pas on n'en sait rien on
comprend pas le risque bafouille
bertrand et ses deux copains ils sont
venus de lyon faire l'aclu du [ __ ] mais
la météo et leur connaissance du
canyoning les en a dissuadés
l'aclu du [ __ ] c'est la plus meurtrière
des alpes-maritimes août 95
trois adolescents pourtant encadrés par
un guide sont emportés par une soudaine
montée des eaux
l'année suivante même scénario un homme
de 53 ans trouve la mort lui aussi noyé
pour stopper cette série noire la
préfecture prend un arrêté qui
réglemente la pratique du canyoning
s'est arrêté vise trois objectifs
essentiels
le premier c'est de définir des sites et
des horaires de parcours
le second objectif c'est concernant
l'encadrement du canyonisme et le
troisième objectif vise un certain
nombre de recommandations pour la
pratique du canyonisme aucun groupe de
plus de 8 personne n'est autorisé à
s'engager dans une crue
certains canyon les plus dangereux sont
carrément interdit draconien aussi des
horaires d'entrée de sortie dans les
torrents il faut limiter les risques une
décision bien accueillie par les
professionnels
pour les professionnels c'était déjà ça
faisait partie de l'évidence de la
pratique quoi donc ça ça a été fait
quand même bien en collaboration aussi
avec les professionnels donc car aucun
problème par rapport à ça et je pense
que c'est d'autant mieux afin qu'ils
essaieraient de sécurité les passionnés
comme bertrand ont plutôt l'impression
de faire les frais de la mode canyon et
de son exploitation commerciale
on se retrouve embêté parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui veulent en faire plein
de gens qui veulent prendre des risques
mais qui veulent pas les assumer et nous
on subit les règles préfectoral depuis
l'arrêté préfectoral il n'y a plus de
décès dans les clous des alpes-maritimes
juste quelques déçus et 10000 personnes
qui en profitent chaque été le canyoning
fait partie de ces nouveaux sports de
l'extrême ils connaissent de plus en
plus de succès en france bien encadré et
à condition respecter ce truc plus
scrupuleusement les consignes et de
consulter la météo les risques
d'accident sont malgré tout mais nîmes
le reportage dans le vercors de virginie
pichet et de philippe iv
la température de l'eau et de 13°
laroche et glissantes en matière de
sécurité la combinaison étanche le
casque et le baudrier sont donc
incontournables les avant de se lancer
l'interrogation primordial reste celle
du ciel comme chaque matin yves
maddalena moniteurs brevetés a pris
connaissance de la météo
le temps est à l'orage soit alors âgée
au dessus de nos têtes
souaid et ailleurs donc un peu pour
éviter ce genre de loterie c'est pour ça
qu'on vient ici aujourd'hui
ce ruisseau est en effet réputé sûr mais
yannick ne laisse rien au hasard et sur
des périodes comme en ce moment on est
la pluie toute la nuit les apportant
quand même avant de rentrer dans des
cagnottes de vérifier le débit d'eau ou
10 mois les fonctionnement spécifique de
certains canyon
ici c'est le barrage qui régule le débit
d'eau maintenu à 40 litres seconde le
lit du furon est ainsi accessible même
par temps de pluie
habituellement les groupes fréquente un
autre canyon aujourd'hui l'incertitude
météo a poussé yannick a modifié son
programme l'autre canyon ova d'habitude
est beaucoup plus bordée de parois
abruptes qui en cas de problème ou
éventuellement en cas de montée des eaux
rendre la sortie plus délicate à
quelques niveaux qu'on soit dans celui
là par exemple qui est bordée de berges
forestière il ya beaucoup plus de
sentiers qui permette de sortir
rapidement au cas où le besoin se fait
sentir
cette ultime rempart contre les caprices
des éléments achète de rassurer le
public est apparemment le
les dangers l'orage effet écarté donc ça
m'a pas impressionné non or avec le
barrage depuis le la personne qu'ils
accompagnent on est vachement assure
bien accompagner en france les moniteurs
diplômés d'état doivent en effet
justifier de deux ans de pratique pour
pouvoir exercer les 35 heures martine
aubry a donc présenté ce matin au
conseil des ministres le texte de sa
deuxième loi elle sera débattue à
l'assemblée à partir du 5 octobre
cette présentation a été l'occasion pour
jacques chirac de rappeler ses doutes
sur l'adaptation de cette loi aux
besoins de notre temps des réserves
qu'ils avaient déjà manifesté à
plusieurs reprises alors que lionel
jospin lui apporter son soutien à
martine aubry si voyons d'abord avec
hugo plagnard les principales
dispositions de ce texte
pas à pas martine aubry impose sa loi
sur les 35 heures
un second texte rend cette fois
obligatoire la baisse de la durée du
travail à partir du 1er janvier 2000
pour les entreprises de plus de 20
salariés
le 1er janvier 2002 pour les autres
avant même que la loi ne soit votée les
35 heures ont commencé à devenir une
réalité grâce aux aides financières de
l'état
rappelez vous il ya un an on nous disait
ça ne marchera jamais souvent dans ce
pays on nous disait les entreprises ne
vont pas négocier et puis très vite plus
d'une sur deux ont négocié on nous
disait ça créera jamais d'emploi et
quand j'en avais annoncé 48000 pour
l'année 99 on avait dit c'est pas
possible on en est déjà à 100 milles au
milieu de la nuit dans un premier temps
les salariés au smic qui travailleront
35 heures seront payées 39 pour les
autres rien ne change
autres chantiers les heures
supplémentaires l'an prochain de l'a35 à
la 39e elles ne seront majorées que de
10% retour au taux normal de 25 % en
2001 un geste pour les employeurs qui
pourront toujours recourir à 130 heures
supplémentaires par an et par salarié
pour les cadres la loi on distingue
trois catégories les dirigeants eux ne
sont pas concernés par le texte
en revanche les cadres soumis à des
horaires collectifs seront au même
régime que les autres salariés
quant aux commerciaux et ceux qui gèrent
leur temps de travail eux-mêmes ils
bénéficieront de 10 jours de congé en
plus par an la loi prévoit enfin des
allègements de charges jusqu'à 21 1500
francs par salarié embauché au smic par
exemple
coût total pour les finances publiques
40 milliards de francs supporter en
partie par la sécurité sociale et
l'assurance chômage
le rpr des dents ce soir une loi
autoritaire et anti-économique
démocratie libérale dénonce l'entêtement
et la volonté de passer en force du
gouvernement
quant aux syndicats ils se montrent
réservées pour certains comme la cgt qui
demande que le texte soit améliorée ou
bien franchement hostile comme la cgpme
pour les petites entreprises et surtout
le medef qui parle de jours sombres pour
les entreprises françaises
alors nous y reviendrons dans un instant
avec vous et renaissante one seillière
mais tout de même vous allez voir avec
ce reportage dans une pme de
pontault-combault en seine-et-marne que
mettre les patrons ne sont pas opposés à
ce genre de pratique cyrille devaud et
delphine pétri des pompes pour
climatiseurs les 43 salariés de cette
pme en produisent deux cent mille par an
les climatiseurs ça se vend surtout
l'été lorsqu'il fait chaud en ce moment
le carnet de commandes est complet
l'entreprise tourne à plein régime
depuis le 1er juillet l'entreprise est
passée aux 35 heures payées 39
désormais le temps de travail est
calculé sur l'année 224 jours par
salarié
les horaires sont flexibles jusqu'à 45
heures par semaine au plus fort de
l'activité seulement 32 eur l'hiver avec
12 jours de repos supplémentaires pour
tout le monde
en plus des congés payés c'était déjà un
peu plus de chez nous quoi les personnes
qu'ils ont des enfants pourront profiter
de leurs enfants et nous sortir un peu
plus en contrepartie de cette réduction
du temps de travail
la direction a convaincu les salariés
d'augmenter les cadences
les pièces parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de commandes et puis bon bah ya
toujours des commandites on est on
obligé de
travail de productivité accrue
annualisation flexibilité une aubaine
pour la direction plus de stock à gérer
plus d'heures supplémentaires à payer
est moins de travailleurs intérimaires
économie cent cinquante mille francs
nets par an malgré cela pas question
d'embaucher dans l'immédiat c'est pas
dans cet esprit là qu'on utilisait le
texte de loi on a essayé d'utiliser le
texte pourrait organiser nos activités
en interne si accessoirement on peut
créer des emplois pourquoi c'est pas la
priorité de l'entreprise
la priorité c'est de faire des bénéfices
et pour ça les cadres ne comptent pas
leurs allemagne etats unis australie
deux tiers du marché se trouve à
l'étranger ce sont les commerciaux comme
maurice perez qui sillonnent les routes
à la recherche de nouveaux clients
il a toujours travaillé largement plus
de trente neuf plus on a de travail et
plus on n'a finalement que de
rémunération parce qu'en fait on est on
est aussi rémunérés sur le sol et
commission donc pour nous - travailler
si on a gagné
maurice perez oublie volontiers de
prendre la route des vacances
il nous a confié qu'il n'utiliserait pas
la totalité de ses douze jours de congés
supplémentaires
voilà alors monsieur c'est à dire
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
on l'a vu dans ce reportage un certains
patrons y trouvent leur compte on parle
beaucoup de flexibilité c'est quand même
un jour sombre pour vous oui c'est un
jour sombre pour les entreprises pour
les salariés pour le dialogue social
pour l'emploi dans notre pays pour
l'avenir économique et social dont vous
voyez vous nous les entrepreneurs nous
ni non ils ne l'ont pas par par quatre
chemins bien entendu ça veut pas dire à
35 ans n'est pas n'est pas faisable et
l'entreprise que l'on on a vu la
l'instant montre bien que c'est faisable
mais parce que flexibilité réduction des
charges sont des choses que vous
revendiquez depuis toujours c'est là la
gorge non mais la majorité avec avec
cette loi là non imposée à un million
deux cent mille entreprises de france
le même jour le même régime des 35
heures a toujours été considérée depuis
le début comme une erreur et personne ne
sait vraiment rallier mais que voulez
vous la politique impose qu'on continue
dans cette voie il ya onze mille
entreprises qui ont réussi à mettre en
place les 35 sur un million deux cent
mille ça fait moins de une sur 100 alors
c'est vraiment pas un succès et nous
nous disons la première loi celle qui a
été votée il ya un an a été un ratage
et c'est parce que c'est un échec
d'ailleurs que le gouvernement
pour ne pas casser l'emploi même pas
casser l'expansion repousse d'un an son
application c'est parce que dit martine
aubry aujourd'hui il indique au
contraire ces derniers mois ces deux
derniers mois notamment au contraire les
accords se sont multipliées qu'on a eu
la création de cent mille cent mille
emplois donc elle dit on ne peut pas
dire aujourd'hui que les 35 heures ne
marche et martine aubry avec beaucoup
d'acharnement et c'est de dire que son
truc marche alors ça je peux pas le lui
empêché de dire mais nous ne sommes pas
d'accord nous pensons en réalité les 35
heures ne marche pas quand on veut les
imposer à tous
eh bien vous savez nous avons deux cent
mille entreprises qui nous ont écrit une
lettre modèle pour madame aubry pour lui
de l'écouté je vous en prie écoutez nous
respecter nous ne vous lancez pas comme
ça dans quelque chose qui est
entièrement travailler avec vos
fonctionnaires vos inspecteurs du
travail vos contrôleurs de la sécurité
sociale c'est pas comme ça qu'on fera
tourner notre pays il faut écouter les
gens qui organisent une entreprise qui
décret qui les développent et faire
attention qu'ils ne se découragent pas
alors nous nous sommes très très alarmés
par cette deuxième vous allez passion ne
pas être écouté par le gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous allez dire à vos à
vos adhérents de leur dire de quoi de
faire de la résistance de refuser
d'appliquer la loi comment ça se passe
et non on va leur dire en effet de ne
pas se presser parce que tout ceci est
très confus et puis vous savez on a vu
par exemple des gouvernements
nationalisé à tour de bras et puis des
années après ba privatisé à tour de bras
alors en ce moment est en tain de
réglementer à tour de bras nous serons
le seul en europe est soumis à une loi
d'une formidable complexité une
véritable usine à gaz alors nous disons
c'est peut-être que sous peu tout même
l'opinion publique peut être même les
parlementaires pendant le débat s'en
rend compte que tout ceci finalement
c'est très exagéré c'est pas réaliste
vous irez en traînant les pieds en
quelque sorte et vous n'êtes pas
mécontent d'avoir un sursis d'un an pour
l'application de la loi ce sursis d'un
an vous savez on à la corde au cou on
peut tirer dessus à tout moment ça nous
rassure pas mais pour nous c'est un aveu
en effet de ce que le gouvernement au
fond a reconnu que son affaire ne
fonctionnait pas ne marchait pas et nous
avons notre part évidemment pour l'avoir
aidé à prendre conscience de cela merci
beaucoup entre seillière d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir les rapports de
forces restent les mêmes au sein du
gouvernement depuis les élections
européennes les verts attendait un
remaniement qui tiennent compte de
renouveau poids politique il n'en sera
rien lionel jospin a procédé à un
remaniement purement technique de son
gouvernement en nommant dominique gillot
socialiste à la santé pour succéder à
bernard kouchner qui partent comme vous
savez au kosovo et en remplaçant au
passage jacques dont douce le secteur
d'état au commerce extérieur a dit qu'à
de gauche par un autre représentant du
parti radical françois johann
ce soir les verts par le d'occasions
ratées précise que dominique voynet
aurait en fait refuser certaines
propositions de lionel jospin qu'elle
jugeait insuffisante
robert hue lui se réjouit pour le parti
communiste de ce statu quo de quoi
alimenter les conversations au dîner que
lionel jospin offre ce soir à l'ensemble
de son gouvernement avant de partir en
vacances
la france condamné pour torture par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme du
jamais vu jusqu'à présent seule la
turquie avait été condamné pour les
mêmes raisons par deux fois à l'origine
de cette décision les sévices ce qu'a dû
endurer un trafiquant de drogue au cours
de sa garde à vue
patrick fandio la sphère n'a pas déplacé
les grandes foules pourtant sous l'oeil
attentif de la représentante française
les deux juges de la cour européenne
vont lire un arrêt qui fera date
deux dit qu'il y avait eu violation de
l'article apprendre violé les articles 3
et 6 de la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme
elle n'a pas assuré ahamed selmi au
procès rapide et surtout elle s'est
livrée à son encontre à des actes de
torture
c'était en novembre 91 selmouni ce
trafiquant de drogue et arrêté
il subira un interrogatoire pour le
moins musclée derrière les murs de ce
commissariat de bobigny coup de poing au
pied ou de batte de baseball des sévices
confirmée par des certificats médicaux
mais les cinq officiers de police mis en
cause ont toujours nié les faits leur
première condamnation en mars dernier à
de la prison ferme avaient scandalisé
leurs collègues déclenchant un bruyant
mouvement de grogne sans précédent ces
peines ont finalement été réduite à de
la prison avec sursis
le 1er juillet pour l'avocate de ahmed
selmouni la décision européenne est une
victoire du droit un droit qui n'aurait
jamais dû être bafoué par des
fonctionnaires de police
la personne parfaitement en sécurité
elle doit être entendue dans le strict
respect de la loi et c'est pas parce
qu'il a commis les pires crimes qu'on
peut le lyncher lui taper dessus mais
uriner tu sais pas assez pas longer
l'arrêt de la cour européenne à gaz des
syndicats de police pour eux c'est une
intrusion dans un dossier encore en
attente à la cour de cassation
je trouve pour ma part un peu fort de
café alors que la procédure nationale
interne judiciaire n'a pas encore abouti
qu une procédure internationale puisse
trancher sur le fond sur un dossier
qu'elle n'a pas celui depuis le début le
dossier selmouni ne sera pas rouvert il
n'y aura a priori pas d'autres procès
mais la france est symboliquement
sanctionné elle se retrouve au même rang
que la turquie qui est loin d'être une
référence en matière des droits de
l'homme à bruxelles les participants à
la conférence des donateurs pour la
reconstruction du kosovo se dit
satisfait à la veille du sommet de
sarajevo sur l'avenir des balkans
il estime avoir réussi à rassembler
suffisamment de fonds pour couvrir les
besoins les plus urgents
il s'agit de reconstruire les maisons
les écoles les centres de soins de
rétablir les réseaux d'eau et des fous
de l'électricité au total
l'engagement des participants se monte à
2 milliards de dollars
cette réunion de bruxelles avait lieu
alors que les habitants de graz co
procédaient aux obsèques des quatorze
paysans serbes tués vendredi dernier
quatre personnes ont été interpellées
par la police militaire mais pour
l'instant l'enquêté n'a rien donné et le
village de grâce qu avait été placé sous
haute protection sur place
agnès vahramian et jean françois renaud
il n'ya pas d'églises orthodoxes à
drapeau ses habitants n'ont jamais
construit pour prier ils rejoignaient
leurs lieux saints le monastère de
grazia nizza à quelques kilomètres de là
c'est donc en plein air dans un champ au
centre du village que les peuples donne
les derniers sacrements
si on les croire quelques vêtements en
offrande et des couronnes mortuaires
confectionné par ces paysans dans la
foule des serbes d'autres villages de
pristina des officiels de belgrade et
bernard kouchner 14 morts que l'on porte
en pertes elles des martyrs d'un nouveau
chapitre de l'histoire des serbes au
kosovo la volonté des serbes de rester
une grande que le désir de ceux qui
sèment la terreur et qui veulent les
voir partir ce ne sont pas les premiers
crimes au kosovo où les serbes connu
depuis 100 ans
les cribles des séparatistes
ce matin alors que ces enterrements se
préparait quatre albanais des villages
alentour ont été arrêtés par la kfor
ils sont considérés comme des suspects
sans que l'on en sache beaucoup plus les
nations unies à graco voudrais au plus
vite
opposer la justice à la violence et à
l'histoire
après la rencontre israélo-palestinienne
des rays une rencontre au cours de
laquelle et août barak a demandé à
yasser arafat de modifier l'accord de
wye plantation notamment sur la question
du rythme du retrait israélien de
cisjordanie
yasser arafat a téléphoné à bill clinton
pour lui faire part de son impatience
messieurs barak et arafat se sont donnés
en principe une quinzaine de jours pour
réfléchir à la question
les sanctions américaines contre les
produits européens et français entrent
en vigueur demain une surtaxe de 100 %
décidée par washington pour protester
vous le savez contre le refus de
l'europe d'importer du boeuf aux
hormones américain
comment à new york les importateurs de
ces produits pour la plupart de luxe se
prépare-t-il à faire face à cette mesure
réponse de philippe gassot aux états
unis le différend commence par une
bavette ou peut-être une entrecôte ou
alors un filet mignon le taux américain
et engraissés aux hormones
ici on prétend que le dopage animal est
inoffensif et que si l'europe empêche
l'importation de viande américaine
c'est en fait du protectionnisme
sournois l'opinion publique suit je suis
dans la viande depuis 35 ans j'ai jamais
vu quelqu'un de malade après avoir mangé
du boeuf américain
personnellement je suis jamais eu de
problème je connais personne qui ait eu
des soucis
l'avion du s est refusée sur le vieux
continent
washington réagi certains produits
importés d'europe seront taxés à 100% et
c'est la france qui va payer le plus
lourd tribut ceux qui sont chargés de la
promotion des produits français
descendre dans la rue
il leur faut motiver commerçants et
clients afin de pouvoir résister son
travail c'est le terrain elle ne
travaille c'est effectivement de sur le
point de vente des produits français a
continué à tourner bien sûr et puis
travailler avec les consommateurs je
crois que les consommateurs sur ce type
de produits ne sont pas aussi sensible
aux évolutions de prix parce qu'on est
quand même sur des produits très haut de
gamme dans le collimateur des américains
le jambon la moutarde le foie gras les
truffes le chocolat le roquefort
autant de produits qui ne sont pas bon
marché mais sans équivalent les
fournisseurs français inquiets espère
quand même que le client suivra même à
la hausse si le roquefort augmente de 30
à 35%
est ce que vous allez continuer à
acheter
si je veux que mon mari continue être
heureux oui continuez à faire acheter
français même au prix fort nos agents
très spéciaux vont devoir être persuasif
las le roquefort et prix du bonheur la
mauvaise nouvelle des vacances c'est
peut-être la hausse des prix de
l'essence plus 12 centimes pour le super
sans plomb des hausses essentiellement
due à la politique de l'opep les
explications de yann frontier de
marie-laure le genre voici un geste
presque anodin qui coûte pourtant de
plus en plus cher 10 à 15 centimes en
moyenne par litre de carburant depuis le
début du mois de juillet une hausse
passée presque inaperçue auprès de
certains automobilistes
j'étais pauvreté a augmenté des états
unis etats unis c'est 400 le char ici en
france après une augmentation pourtant
sans commune mesure avec celle du baril
de brut et de sa valeur étalon le brent
qui a atteint le 14 juillet dernier son
plus haut niveau depuis un peu moins de
deux ans un envol qui s'explique par la
décision de l'opep l'organisation des
pays exportateurs de pétrole de réduire
sa production
autre raison la baisse brutale des
exportations du nigeria due à
l'instabilité politique et la chute des
réserves américaines en janvier le brise
le brent qui est l'autre brut de
récurrence coûtait 10 $ 40 aujourd'hui
il coûte plus de dix heures c'est à dire
90 % d'augmentation
et encore si on tenait compte du fait
que le dollar est lui-même augmenté
pendant cette période si plus de 100 %
d'augmentation
et cette augmentation n'en est qu'à ses
débuts car il ya toujours un décalage de
15 jours à 1 mois entre les fluctuations
du cours du pétrole et leurs
répercussions à la pompe hausse annoncée
dès le mois prochain
plus qu'un centime à nouveau mais les
pétroliers ne sont pas les seuls
responsables de ces tarifs très élevés
en france il faut le rappeler les taxes
de l'état représentent 83 % du prix de
l'essence
ils étaient quatre cet après midi quatre
ministres et secrétaires d'état pour
lancer la campagne d'information sur les
dangers de l'équipe ce duo 11 août
danger pour les yeux a dit martine aubry
si on ne se munit pas de ces fameuses
lunettes à 5 francs même si certains ont
du mal à les trouver en vente pour
l'instant et puis danger sur la route
des gens claude gayssot qui maintient
son interdiction de circulation aux
poids lourds pendant la durée de
l'éclipsé
malgré les protestations de leur
syndicat et puisque l'on regarde le ciel
quelques mots de la navette spatiale
columbia avec à son bord le spationaute
français michel tonini
elle s'est posée sans encombre à cap
canaveral en floride après cinq jours de
la mission
tout a parfaitement fonctionné et le
plus grand télescope un télescope
détecteur de rayons x a été déployé dans
l'espace
le retour de marie jo pérec c'était il
ya quelques instants à lahti en finlande
sur 200 m après près de deux ans
d'absence pour maladie florent gautreau
un petit stade de province au fin fond
de la finlande un meeting discret devant
un public plus habitué aux sports
d'hiver marie josé pérec fait son retour
dans une ambiance confinée face à des
adversaires peu renommée et très local
puisqu'il y a 6 finlandaise à ses côtés
les règles qui n'a plus couru depuis
près de deux ans s'apprête à retrouver
l'une de ses distance préférée le 200 m
au couloir 4 en jaune à la française
semble plus crispé que d'habitude mais
on retrouve vite cette foulée ample qui
lui a permis de devenir triple
championne olympique
quant à l'entamé de la ligne droite
marie josé pérec est en retard on se dit
qu'elle va doubler ses adversaires comme
avant mais perec va être battu par la
modeste finlandaise ioana manninen en 23
secondes 65 la française est bien loin
de ses meilleurs temps quand vous n'avez
pas couru pendant deux ans vous perdez
tous vos repères
vous ne ressentait plus les mêmes choses
qu'avant vous devez tout recommencer à
zéro et c'est tout simplement ce que je
suis en train de faire des règles se
souvient de sa gloire passée et elle
sait qu'elle doit travailler
la mononucléose qui l'a éloigné des
pistes l'a affaibli mais ne l'a pas
anéanti la course d'aujourd'hui lui a
juste montré que le chemin serait long
de la ti à sydney et nous partons
maintenant pour la roque d'anthéron
retrouver michel mompontet ses invités
michel l'arrogant theron est un petit
village dans les bouches-du-rhône pas
facile à trouver sur une carte de
m'avait dit mais depuis 19 ans c'est là
que se déroule le plus grand festival
international de piano
effectivement depuis 19 ans petit à
petit année après année ce petit village
du luberon et bien devenu l'authentic
capitale du piano alors ce que j'ai à
côté de moi et je voulais juste vous
montrer ce n'est pas le bottin mondain
où le bottin des bouches du rhône c'est
tout simplement les 289 pages de
l'extraordinaire programme concocté dans
ces lieux alors c'est vrai qu'il ya des
artistes mais il y a peut être avant
tout un cadre un cadre extraordinaire un
cadre extraordinaire où les artistes du
monde entier viennent jouer après après
année avec une fidélité qui se démonte
pas bien sûr joué dans les temps des
zones de saint martin de crau ou dans
les carrières de
rogne ou encore dans l'abbaye de jouques
c'est un formidable pari mais c'est un
formidable de paris qui caresse
quasiment gagné d'avancé pardon quand on
sait que chaque fois l'acoustique de ces
lieux est absolument extraordinaire pour
honorer le roi ici qui s'appelle bien
sûr le piano benoît alors c'est très
joli michel vous avez je crois à côté de
vous rené martin qui est à l'origine de
ce festival c'est lui aussi qui a créé
les folles journées de nantes d'ailleurs
et il a accepté que vous le suiviez
toute une journée dans la route piétons
de la roque d'anthéron fait attention en
traversant la rue ici un piano peut en
cacher un autre et dans tous les lieux
du village jusqu'au plus insolites comme
ce garage le piano est un roi bucolique
parfois insolites mais toujours
omniprésent
des sorties des branchages des buissons
rené martin n'a que faire à laroque
depuis 19 ans maintenant ce que martin
veut dieu le veut et aujourd'hui il a
décidé que pour le soir même il faudrait
ici une loge pour lui seul compte le
désir de faciliter la vie des artistes
et l'intendance doit suivre coûte que
coûte
tout doit être prêt pour la musique
rendre compte qu'on soit obligé de de
l'aider au maximum pour que
techniquement on puisse répondre à ces
aspirations artistiques
il a une idée il faut que ça marche bien
on essaie et ça marche
ou plutôt ça couvre au pas de charge et
si les musiciens sont si nombreux ici
c'est peut-être d'abord parce que rené
martin dm les aime autant qu'ils aiment
la musique
non
ils soir après soir rené martin revient
s'asseoir au premier rang comme s'il
veut y ait non seulement sur un concert
mais aussi sur une réunion d'amis
alors rené martin bonsoir je crois que
c'est une idée un peu folle de créer un
festival dans un petit village comme
celui-là de temps je crois que d'après
votre votre formation musicale à musique
classique c'est pas tout à fait votre
tasse de thé alors qu'est-ce qui quelle
mouche vous a piqué c'est la rencontre
avec le président paul onoratini le
président du festival actuel qui était
maire de laroque qui c'était un village
magnifique y avait surtout un cadre
absolument unique avec ses talent et
hanane magnifique et surtout un cadre
pour construire une conque acoustique
qui a transformé le lieu est donc chaque
année maintenant nous avons 70 concerts
à peu près dans le cadre uniquement de
la roque d'anthéron
je ne compte pas évidemment tous les
villages aux alentours des villages du
bouches-du-rhône où nous animons aussi
par des pianistes par des orchestres par
des choeurs alors je sais pas ce que je
dois me l'a dit que quand vous étiez
jeune vous étiez plutôt un fan de rock
et vous étiez vous-même batteur et j'ai
l'impression que me chercher avec ce
festival d'élargir à d'autres publics
le monde de la musique classique est ce
que nous montrons oui c'est vrai c'est
vrai que je suis de la génération de la
guitare électrique
moi quand j'étais enfant j'étais jeune
je n'écoutais que tous les que des
groupes de rock
mais j'ai rencontré la musique classique
et je me suis dit ma vocation c'est
peut-être de créer ces rencontres là
pour donner envie à des gens qui
écoutent d'autres musiques de venir
écouter ce répertoire magnifique de
mozart alors nous interrompt une seconde
là parce que je crois que l'une des plus
fidèles de ce festival c'est brigitte
tiger la grande cadix française alors
avant de la retrouver mais je vous
propose de l'écouter lors d'une
répétition avec le flûtiste philippe
berthold
elle répète une sonate de flûte et piano
de francis poulenc
e
brigitte hanger bonsoir alors qu'est ce
qui vous plaît tant dans ce dans ce
festival de la roque d'anthéron c'est
que j'aime à l'inventaire on sait que
l'ambiance est extrêmement détendu
chaleureuse et en même temps tout est
très professionnel tout est fait pour
que nous soyons heureux musicalement et
pour que nous puissions donner le
meilleur de nous mêmes alors justement
je parlais avec un pianiste cet après
midi il me disait le passage entre les
loges et la scène alors d'anthéron moi
j'appelle ça le couloir glam ça c'est
vrai là je suis détendu et rentabilité à
jouer alors qu'on est dans un tout petit
village du luberon oui mais en même
temps le public qui est là est un public
qui aime le piano qui tous les soirs
vient écouter de grands artistes
confirmés ou de jeunes espoirs
donc c'est vrai qu'on a envie d'être
meilleur de soi même mais il faut dire
que ce chemin là entre la loge et la
scène ne sommes toujours accompagné par
rené il nous tient la main il use amène
comme comme un père jusqu au piano alors
il ya un monsieur dont on n'aura pas
besoin de tenir la main parce que c'est
un immense artiste et il va nous prouver
que le piano ce n'est pas seulement
chopin et liszt à la roque d'anthéron
c'est aussi la salsa découvert pareils
cooder qui disait de lui il est le fils
spirituel de thelonious monk et de félix
le chat j'ai le très grand bonheur de
finir cette page spéciale avec quelqu'un
que nous admirons ici particulièrement
seniors web en falaise x files
d'autocars
à
bon
on est désolé de vous on est désolé de
vous quitter merci merci à vous michel
merci à tous vos invités puis bon
festival à la roque d'anthéron
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
en rappelle les deux principaux titres
la suisse est sous le choc après
l'accident des gorges de sacs si de bach
qui a fait 19 morts et deux disparus
tous participent est à une descente de
canyoning l'enquète s'annonce difficile
seule une météo imprévu semble être pour
l'instant l'origine de cette catastrophe
et puis les 35 heures martine aubry a
présenté le texte de la deuxième loi au
conseil des ministres de ce matin selon
elle cent mille emplois ont déjà été
créés ou sauvegardés grâce à ce
dispositif les syndicats se montrent un
peu plus réservé quant au président du
medef ernest antoine seillière vous
l'avez entendu il est franchement
hostile à ce texte dans un instant la
météo ce sera patrice drevet à 20h55 sur
un air de mambo un téléfilm français
avec catherine jacob
le téléjournal vers zéro heure 20 sera
très crotta demain à 7h50 dans les 4
vérités marie pierre farkas recevra nick
dissaux adjointe au maire de paris à 13
heures l'autre voie bien sûr
carole gaessler et rachid arhab quant à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain soir à 20h bonne soirée sur
france 2